at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's
famous chili the trick is to undercook
the onions everybody is going to get to
know each other in the pot I'm serious
about this stuff I'm up the night before
pressing garlic and dicing whole
Tomatoes I toast my own ancho chiles
it's a recipe passed down from Malone's
for generations it's probably the thing
I do best
have you been introduced to Kevin no
which one's Kevin
he's here on a special worker program
he's slow you know in his brain
oh good for you guys yeah well you know
my my name is Raja Uganda and I hate it
I hate it I thought watching the condo
was a boy's name I just want to lie on
the beach and eat hot dogs that's all
I've ever wanted this camp with a stamp
of your book take care of it
oh yes I can in general they do not give
me much responsibility but they do let
me shred the company documents and that
is really all I need
nope it's not Ashton Kutcher its Kevin
Malone it Willie handsome
equally smart accounting department
listen up Holly Human Resources Angela
Oscar and Kevin hello hello what do you
do I do the numbers oh good for you
do you want to M&M
oh no that is so sweet thank you though
yeah I keep them here at my desk so that
everybody doesn't take them well that is
a very safe place for them it'll shred
we really don't do a lot of weddings we
actually don't play in public very often
we are all really hoping that Pam's
wedding works out this could be a
turning point for the band oh yeah you
haven't seen that since 1980 I kinda
know what it's like to be in commercials
my nickname in high school used to be
kool-aid man please hold
Andy phone call nope stay there keV I
thought we nailed the whole transfer
thing earlier yeah I wrote it on my hand
but can I washed it it is transfer
extension and then transfer again okay
Andy get ready transfer here we go
attention thanks ah man it is 134 yeah
come on hustle pull are murdering the
dark
this is Kevin please hold and I will
transfer you you're bad at this - don't
answer that call just transfer the day
I'm go your call is very important to us
[Applause]
my maid died what are you doing
let's go over some of these symptoms of
marijuana use
shall we you tell me who this sounds
like slow-moving inattentive dull
constantly snacking shows a lack of
motivation I just wanted to say that
just my mom's coming in today FML
thanks Kevin I bet Roy heard about you
liking Pam I bet he'll try to beat you
up
thanks for the heads up Joe I got your
back if he does
but try to stay out of it who wrote this
this hysterical one anal fissures that's
a real thing yeah but no one here has it
someone has it
I hear Angela's party will have double
fudge brownies it will also have Angela
so double fudge Angela double fudge
Angela we're cool right
yes yeah all right cool man sweet
oh no it's bad it's real bad it's like
eating a hot circle of garbage hey hey
you want to go to the beach sure you
want to get high no I think you do mom
what are the odds
this isn't anyway real
I'd say like ten thousand to one okay
I'd like ten bucks on those odds if
someone gives you ten thousand to one on
anything you take it if John Mellencamp
ever wins an Oscar I am going to be a
very rich dude ooh can I be absolutely
hello mate I like ice cream
I need a boyfriend I like ice cream too
mate any date tossing dingo babies man I
should have gotten some food maybe some
spaghetti okay
Kevin you can take off that thing okay
oh hello Oscar how was your vacation
that's very funny yeah I thought of that
like two seconds after you left do you
need some help I can't decide what to
get well what do you like to eat well I
like pretzels but I really like chips
hmm well how much money do you have
there
50 this is a button 55 65 okay you have
75 cents so that means you could get
anything up in the top row I am totally
gonna bang Holly she is cute and helpful
and she really seems into me
[Applause]
where'd you get that salad staples
Angela's cats are cute so cute that you
just want to eat them but you can't eat
cats you can't eat cats Kevin I thought
they'd be good together like PB&J Pam
Beesly and Jim what a waste
as God is my witness I will quit if this
is not fixed some of us like to walk
more than others oh hell what and the
awesome party the best wedding I've ever
been to
I got six numbers one more would have
been a complete telephone number this
was epic my Kleenex shoes were a huge
conversation piece but man my dogs are
barking
my feet were so sweaty
I can't even build a coal after Stacey
left things did not go well for a while
and it was hard to see it's just nice to
win one
you